This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. In 1980, a bomb exploded at the central train station in Bologna, Italy. 85 people were killed. Hundreds were injured. In the wake of the attack, which was later blamed on an Italian terrorist organization, a large clock on the outside of the train station stopped working. The clock, frozen at 10.2525 became a symbol of the attack. The picture of the clock was plastered all over posters and banners during commemorations of the event for years afterwards. The clock was quickly repaired,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。1980年，意大利博洛尼亚中央火车站发生了一起爆炸。85人死亡。数百人受伤。袭击发生后，这起事件后来被归咎于一个意大利恐怖组织，火车站外的一个大钟停走了。这座钟定格在10点25分，成了袭击的象征。在随后的多年里，这口钟的照片在纪念活动的各种海报和横幅上随处可见。这钟很快就被修复了，
but in 1996, 16 years after the bombing, city officials permanently stopped the clock at 10.25 in remembrance of the tragedy. In so doing, they unwittingly set up a psychological experiment. Decades later, when asked whether the clock had ever been fixed, the vast majority of city residents incorrectly reported that it had not. That included 21 employees of the train station who presumably saw the clock on a regular basis. It's not difficult to understand how this error might have come about. The stopped clock had become an integral element of the story of the bombing. People's recollections were shaped by the story as much as the facts. We see the same thing happening in settings large and small. Two friends might disagree about an incident that took place when they were in school together,
但在1996年，也就是爆炸发生16年后，市政府官员将这座时钟永远定格在10点25分，以缅怀这场悲剧。在这样做的同时，他们无意中设置了一项心理实验。几十年后，当被问及这座时钟是否被修好过时，绝大多数市民都错误地回答说没有。这其中还包括21名火车站员工，他们理应经常看到这座时钟。不难理解这种错误是如何产生的。停走的钟已经成为轰炸故事中不可或缺的一个元素。人们的回忆不仅由事实塑造，也由故事塑造。我们在大小不同的场景中都能看到同样的事情发生。两个朋友可能会对他们上学时发生的一起事件产生分歧，
years before. Managers and workers may remember different versions of the events that led to a strike, with each group partial to the version that supports its point of view. When countries go to war, millions of people may collectively remember one chronicle of historical wrongs, while millions of people on the other side of a border remember a completely different set of facts. Many of us roll our eyes at people who misremember things to suit their preferred narratives about the world. The one thing we all find hard to do believe that our memories are just as fallible and shaped by our own thoughts, beliefs and stories.
那是很多年前的事了。管理者和工人们对导致罢工的事件可能会有不同的记忆，每一方都偏向于支持自己观点的那个版本。当国家陷入战争时，千百万人可能会集体记住关于历史错误的一种说法，而国境另一边的千百万人则记住了完全不同的一套事实。我们许多人会对那些为了迎合自己对世界的偏好叙事而记错事情的人翻白眼。我们所有人都觉得最难做到的一点，是相信我们自己的记忆同样不可靠，同样会被我们自己的想法、信念和故事所塑造。
This week on Hidden Brain, how preferences, loyalties and the power of suggestion can shape what we remember and what we forget. Long before Elizabeth Loftus became a psychologist and a researcher who studied memory, long before she became one of the world's experts on the way we recollect childhood traumas, she herself suffered three traumatic events as a child. Each of them became, in their own way, emblematic of her research into the slippery, fallible nature of memory. I would say developed depression when I was about 13 years old and She went to Pennsylvania To get some treatment because that's where her brother lived my uncle Joe
本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨偏好、忠诚以及暗示的力量如何塑造我们的记忆和遗忘。在伊丽莎白·洛夫特斯成为一名研究记忆的心理学家和研究人员之前，在她成为世界顶尖的童年创伤回忆专家之一之前，她自己在童年时期就遭遇过三次创伤性事件。这三次经历以各自独特的方式，成为了她对滑坡般、不可靠的记忆本质进行研究的象征。我想说，我大约13岁时患上了抑郁症，然后她去了宾夕法尼亚州接受一些治疗，因为我哥哥住在那里，也就是我的乔叔叔。
I see and were you aware as a 13 year old that your mom was unwell? Well, yes, I was definitely aware. Even before she left to go to Pennsylvania for some treatment, my parents had tickets to different concerts or events. And so my mother couldn't go to one of the events where they had tickets. And so my father took me, I think it might have been a Gilbert and Sullivan play or it might have been,
我明白了。作为一个13岁的孩子，你知道你妈妈生病了吗？嗯，是的，我绝对知道。甚至在她去宾夕法尼亚州接受治疗之前，我父母就买过不同音乐会或活动的票。所以妈妈去不了一场他们有票的活动。然后我父亲带我去了，我想那可能是一部吉尔伯特和沙利文的戏剧，也可能是一部，
well, I can't remember exactly, but I do remember driving back from the play to our house and stopping at a stoplight. And some people were crossing the street, and they were laughing and having a good time, so it would have been after a play ends in Los Angeles, whatever time that would be, and they were having fun, and my father said, see those people having fun,
嗯，我记不清具体是什么了，但我确实记得看完戏后开车回家，在一个红绿灯处停下来。有些人正在过马路，他们在笑，玩得很开心，所以那应该是在洛杉矶的一场戏结束之后，具体是几点就记不清了，他们在玩乐，我父亲说，看那些玩得开心的人，
your mother can't have fun anymore. So that's just one thing that sticks out in my memory now that you're asking. So when she went to Pennsylvania, she went to her brother's home. You said that she went there for treatment. What happened there? Her older brother, you know, my uncle Joe, Her older brother, you know, my uncle Joe, wanted her to get this excellent treatment in a hospital in Pittsburgh. So he brought her, he managed to get her to Pennsylvania, where he got her treatment in a nearby hospital. And then she was released and ready to come home. So I went with my aunt by car to go pick her up
你妈妈再也不能玩得开心了。所以这就是现在你问起时，我记忆中格外清晰的一件事。那么她去宾夕法尼亚州时，是去了她哥哥的家。你说她是去那里治疗的。在那里发生了什么？她的哥哥，你知道的，我的乔叔叔，她的哥哥，你知道的，我的乔叔叔，想让她在匹兹堡的一家医院接受这种极好的治疗。所以他把她带了过来，设法把她弄到了宾夕法尼亚州，并在附近的一家医院给她安排了治疗。然后她出院了，准备回家。所以我跟着我阿姨开车去接她，
and drive her back to California. And she was staying at her brother's. And that's when she was there, she ended up drowning in a swimming pool on my uncle's property in Pennsylvania. So that was horrible. How did that happen, Beth? What happened?
开车送她回加利福尼亚。她当时住在她兄弟家。就在她呆在那里的期间，她最后在我叔叔宾夕法尼亚州的房产里的一座游泳池里溺水身亡。所以那是可怕的。贝丝，那是怎么发生的？发生了什么？
We absolutely don't know, but there was, you know, there were a lot of questions of, was it an accident? Was it a suicide? What was it? But it was never, ever decided. Nothing definitive. I see. So you were actually there when this terrible thing happened, Beth?
我们完全不知道，但是，你知道的，有很多关于这究竟是意外还是自杀的疑问？到底是什么？但这件事从来没有被真正判定过。没有什么确切的结论。我明白了。贝丝，这件可怕的事情发生时，你其实就在现场？
I was, yes. I was 14. And it was terrible. I mean, it was like the worst thing that ever happened to me. Many years later, Beth found herself disagreeing with an uncle about what happened on that terrible day. I went to a family event. In fact, it was like a 90th birthday party of one of my uncles. And while I was there, an uncle said to me, you know, back when your mother died, so that would
是的，我在。我当时14岁。这太可怕了。我的意思是，这就像我经历过的最糟糕的事情。许多年后，贝丝发现自己和一个叔叔对那可怕的一天发生了什么各执一词。我去参加一个家庭活动。事实上，那就像是我的一位叔叔的90岁生日派对。当我在那里时，一个叔叔对我说，你知道，当年你母亲去世的时候，那应该已经是几十年前了，你就是那个发现你母亲尸体的人。我对叔叔说，不，不是我。是我阿姨，我妈妈的妹妹发现了尸体。不是我发现的尸体。噢，是的，就是你。这个亲戚是如此绝对地肯定。于是我回家开始思考，是我发现了尸体吗？我开始努力回忆1959年我母亲溺水的那天到底发生了什么，
have been decades earlier, you were the one who found your mother's body. And I said to my uncle, no, it wasn't me. It was her sister, my aunt who found the body. I'm not the one who found the body. Oh, yes, you were. This relative was so absolutely positive. And so I went home and I started thinking, did I find the body? And I started to try to remember what had happened
并努力回想起1959年母亲溺水那天发生的事情。我确实记得，当911急救人员到达时，消防员最后给我吸了氧。我想也许是因为我太难过了，需要吸氧，因为我发现了尸体，我开始琢磨这个想法，很快我就能看到我母亲
on that day in 1959 when my mother drowned. And I did remember that when the 911 emergency people came, the firemen ended up giving me oxygen. And I thought maybe I was so upset I needed oxygen because I had found the body and I I started working on this idea and Pretty soon I could see my mother
脸朝下、双臂伸开地溺死在游泳池里，我在脑海中想象着这个画面，然后那个亲戚打电话给我说，我打电话是想告诉你我弄错了。发现尸体的人不是你。你是对的，是你阿姨，她的妹妹。我对我刚刚经历的个人体验感到无比惊讶。我成了我自己实验中的被试。
drowned in the swimming pool with face down with her arms out and I was visualizing it and Then the relative called me and said I'm calling to tell you I made a mistake. It wasn't you who found the body. You're right, it was your aunt, her sister. And I was so amazed at the personal experience that I had just had. I was the subject in one of my own experiments.
我的被试就是这种感觉。我的意思是，为什么，你知道的，为什么我的视觉化画面是她脸朝下、双臂伸开？我的意思是，为什么不是仰面朝天，双臂没有伸开呢？我的意思是，我不知道。贝丝童年的另一个创伤性事件发生在她上高中时。她的房子被一场吞噬了大约500栋房屋的加利福尼亚野火所吞没。我当时正开车从高中回家。我开车载着我的弟弟，我的小弟弟大卫。由于大火，街道被封锁了，但我们知道绕过路障的秘密小路，
This is what it's like for my subjects. I mean, why did, you know, why was my visualization with her face down with her arms out? I mean, where did, as opposed to on her back, you know, with no arms out? I mean, I don't know. Another traumatic event from Beth's childhood took place while she was in high school. Her house was engulfed in a California wildfire that burned some 500 houses. I was driving home from high school. I was driving my brother, my younger brother, David. And the streets were blocked off because of the fire, but we knew secret ways to get past the roadblocks and
来到房子前，却发现房子正在被大火吞噬。天哪，看到这一幕时，你的反应是什么？我的意思是，看到……那一定极其具有创伤性。不，我跑进家里去拿几本百科全书，因为我有作业要做。我拿了百科全书，你知道的，还有其他一些东西，然后走到一处完好无损的邻居家，给办公室的父亲打电话说，
get to the house and came upon the house burning down. Oh my God, what was the reaction when you saw that? I mean, it must have been incredibly traumatic to see the... No, I ran in the house to get some encyclopedias, because I had homework to do. And I got my encyclopedias and, you know, a few other items, and went to a neighbor's house that was still intact and called my father at his office and said,
房子已经不在了。贝丝讲述这场大火的故事已经有很多次了。她对这起事件的记忆非常精准，与那些经历过类似事件的人不同，她从不夸张所发生的事情。原因何在？她可能产生的任何添油加醋的叙述，都被一个令人惊讶的文献证据来源所限制。
the house isn't there anymore Beth has told the story of the fire many times Her memory of the incident is precise Unlike others who have been through similar events. She never exaggerates what happened similar events, she never exaggerates what happened. The reason? Any storytelling she might have been tempted to do has been constrained by a surprising source of documentary evidence.
其实我对这件事有所了解，因为当时《生活》杂志的摄影师就在那栋房子里。所以《生活》杂志上有一篇关于这场大火本身、特别是关于我们房子的很长的报道。如果我能给你看《生活》杂志的照片，你就会看到，虽然房子并没有被大火彻底吞噬，但已经有人进屋把我们的一些财产搬出来，移到了一处水泥地上。所以我才有可能进去拿到那些百科全书。这听起来几乎就像是你对我说，你比信任自己的记忆更信任照片。哦，当然。我可以告诉你，因为我在《生活》杂志上看过这些照片很多次，
I actually know something about this because there were photographers at the house from Life Magazine. So there was a very large spread about the fire itself and about our house in particular in Life Magazine. If I could show you the Life Magazine photos, you could see that while the house, it wasn't like it was engulfed in flames, but some people had already gone into the house to pull out some of our possessions and move them onto onto a concrete area. So it was possible for me to go in and get those encyclopedias. And it almost seems like what you're telling me is that you trust the pictures more than you trust your own memories. Oh, absolutely. I can tell you because I've seen these pictures
它显示我站在这个水泥地上看着燃烧的房子。哦，天哪。它显示我和弟弟大卫一起试图搬走一些财产。它显示我在邻居家打电话给父亲。
many times in Life Magazine, and it shows me standing in this concrete area looking at the burning house. Oh, wow. It shows me trying to carry some possessions away with my brother, David. It shows me on the phone at the neighbors calling my father.
哦天哪，哇。把电话贴在耳边说：“爸爸，那房子已经不在了。”它，是的，照片说明了一切。为了解释为什么贝丝比自己的记忆更信任照片，我需要把时钟拨回过去，跟你讲讲她穿越人类记忆迷宫的奇特旅程。
Oh my gosh, wow. The phone to my ear saying, "'Daddy, that house isn't there anymore. It, yeah, the pictures say it all. To explain why Beth trusts the photos more than her memory, I need to wind the clock back and tell you about her strange journey through the labyrinth of human memory.
此外，我们还会谈到她童年的第三个创伤事件。贝丝从未在公开场合谈论过这件事。直到有一天，她在法庭上作为专家证人作证时，突然脱口而出。我当时在作证，谈论的是关于记忆的科学。这些话就这样脱口而出了。这是第一次。当然是第一次我在公开场合脱口而出。我们稍后回来。你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。20世纪70年代初，贝丝·洛夫特斯获得了美国交通部的一笔资助，去研究人们是如何记住涉及车祸的事件的。她是一位初出茅庐的心理学家，她对人类记忆的科学以及这门科学对法律体系的影响都充满兴趣。她得到了
Also, we'll get to that third traumatic event from her childhood. Beth had never spoken in public about this incident. Until one day, she blurted it out while serving as an expert witness in court. I was testifying about the science of memory. And the words just kind of came out. about the science of memory. And the words just kind of came out. It was the first time. Certainly the first time I blurted it out publicly. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the early 1970s, Beth Laftis got a grant from the US Department of Transportation to study how people remembered events involving auto crashes. She was a newly minted psychologist and she was interested both in the science of human memory and the implications of this science for the legal system. She got
警察拍摄的车祸现场录像，并把它们放给志愿者看。我们会向人们展示事故的影片，并询问他们关于车辆速度的问题。不同的证人会以不同的方式接受盘问。因此，我们的一些证人被问到：当两车相撞时，车速有多快？其他证人则被问到：当两车猛烈撞击时，车速有多快？我们可能对其他证人使用了不同的动词。但我们发现，如果使用“猛烈撞击”这个词，人们告诉我们的车速就会比使用“撞击”这个词时更快。
her hands on police videos of traffic crashes and showed them to volunteers. We would show people films of accidents and ask them about the speed of the vehicles. And different witnesses were questioned in different ways. So some of our witnesses are asked how fast were the cars going when they hit each other? Other witnesses are asked how fast were the cars going when they smashed into each other? And we might have used different verbs with other witnesses. But we found that people told us the cars were going faster
因此，我们在当时已经证明，仅仅改变问题中的一两个词，就能对别人给你的答案产生影响。贝丝1974年的研究揭示了人类记忆中微妙的一面。当两辆车被设定为“猛烈撞击”时，它在志愿者的脑海中勾勒出了一幅事故的画面。当贝丝询问人们关于事故的情况时，这个图像以及它在他们脑海中创造的故事，影响了他们的记忆。
if you use the word smashed than if you use the word hit. So what we had shown at that point is just changing a word or two in your question can have an effect on the answer that somebody gave you. Bed study in 1974 reveals something subtle about human memory. When two cars were set to smash into each other, it painted a picture of the crash in volunteers' minds. When Beth asked people about the crash, this image, the story it created in their minds, influenced what they remembered.
贝丝将这项研究推向了深入。我们随后做的是，我们在一个星期后把人们请了回来，我们说，你知道我们上周给你们看的那个事故吗？我们还有几个问题想问你们。我们最关心的一个问题是：你看到任何碎玻璃了吗？他们看过的事故中并没有碎玻璃，然而，如果我们用了“猛烈撞击”这个词，回答说自己看到了碎玻璃的人就会比我们使用“撞击”这个词时更多。由于碎玻璃通常与严重的事故相伴相生，
Beth took the study a step further. What we did then was we brought people back a week later and we said, you know that accident we showed you last week, we have a few more questions for you. And the one we cared about, did you see any broken glass? There was no broken glass in the accident they had seen and yet if we had used the word smashed more people told us falsely that they had seen broken glass than if we had used the word hit. Since broken glass is commensurate with a
一种在更高速度下发生的事故，因此那里更有可能有碎玻璃，然后一些人就会想，是的，他们可能看到了。所以这告诉我们的是，你向证人提问的措辞，不仅会影响你得到的即时答案，还会产生长期的影响。它可能会影响对你向某人提出的某个完全不同问题的回答，你知道的，通常是在这之后的很久很久。
severe accident, one that occurs at higher speeds, it's more likely that there was broken glass there and some people then think, yeah, they probably saw it. So what this told us is that the way you word a question that you put to a witness can affect not only the immediate answer that you get, but it can have a long range of effect. It can affect the answer to some totally different question that you put to somebody, you know, often much much later.
在这项实验的第二部分中，志愿者们创造了从未发生过的视觉细节。他们以为自己在回忆事实，但在不知不觉中，他们的脑海不仅推断出车祸现场有碎玻璃，还凭空捏造出了看到碎玻璃的景象。在“撞击”研究之后，我们做了另一项研究，在其中，
In the second portion of the experiment, volunteers created visual details that never occurred. They thought they were remembering the facts, but without their awareness, their minds had not only inferred the presence of broken glass at the scene of the crash, but fabricated the sight of broken glass. After the smash hit study, we did another study
被试看到的是一场正在展开的事故，比方说，被试看到汽车穿过一个设有让行标志的十字路口。事故结束后，我们提出了一系列问题，其中一个问题旨在暗示一些错误的信息。另一辆车是否在它位于设有停车标志的十字路口时通过了红点？这是一个非常巧妙的问题。你以为我是在问你另一辆车是否通过了，
where what the subject sees is an accident unfold, where, let's say, the subject sees is an accident unfold where let's say the car goes through an intersection with a yield sign. After the accident is over we asked a series of questions and one of them was designed to suggest some erroneous information. Did another car pass the red dots and well it was there at the intersection with the stop sign? This is a very clever question. You think I'm asking you about whether another car passed,
你的注意力集中在问题的那个方面，你说，不，我没有看到另一辆车通过，但我巧妙地塞入了那里有一个停车标志的信息。你没有察觉到，我认为它侵入了人们的脑海，几乎就像一只特洛伊木马，因为你甚至没有察觉到它的到来。后来我们可以问人们，你在十字路口看到了什么交通标志？那是停车标志还是让行标志？
you're concentrating on that aspect of the question, you say, no, I didn't see another car pass, but I have cleverly slipped in the information that there was a stop sign there. You don't detect it and I think it invades people, almost like a Trojan horse, because you don't even detect that it's coming. Later on we can ask people, what kind of a traffic sign did you see there at the intersection? Was it a stop sign or a yield sign?
如果人们屈服于暗示和引导性问题，许多人会选择停车标志。我认为那里发生的事情是，当我问你那个引导性问题——当另一辆车在设有停车标志的十字路口时，它是否通过了红点——你试图在脑海中重现你所看到的，而你只是在你的可视化中插入了一个众所周知的停车标志。后来，当我说，你在那里究竟看到了什么？你基本上会说停车标志，但你看到的是你自己构建的停车标志。从某种意义上说，这是早期研究的一种更隐蔽的形式，在那个研究中，你告诉人们汽车相撞了，然后你问，你看到碎玻璃了吗？在那里，人们会说，嗯，如果汽车相撞了，可能就会有碎玻璃。所以，你知道，也许这是一个推断，也许他们在回忆，也许这是两件事的混杂。但在这种情况下，你是在植入一段记忆，暗示有一个停车标志而不是让行标志。而人们只是安装了他们自己的停车标志，并在后来记起自己看到了它。我确实觉得你在这里展示了记忆被污染的不同方式。一种是我自己在进行推断，
And many people will pick the stop sign if they've succumbed to the suggestion and the leading question. And there I think what is going on is when I ask you that leading question, did another car pass the red dots and while it was there at the intersection with the stop sign, you're trying to visualize what you saw and you just insert a well-known stop sign into your visualization. Later on, when I say, what do you actually see there? You basically say stop sign, but you're seeing a stop sign that you yourself constructed. I mean, in some ways, it's a more insidious form of the earlier study where you tell people the cars have smashed into each other and then you ask, did you see broken glass? There people are saying, well, if the car smashed into each
并将自己引向一个错误的结论。而在接下来的情况下，其他人正在非常微妙地将我引向一个错误的结论。这两件事可以在不同的时间发生，或者借用你那个美妙的词。这可能是一个大杂烩。但我们确实知道，人们确实会就可能发生的事情、可能发生的事情、大概发生的事情做出推断。
other, there was probably broken glass. And so, you know, perhaps it's an inference, perhaps they are recalling it, maybe it's a mishmash between the two things. But in this case, you're implanting a memory where you're suggesting that there's a stop sign instead of a yield sign. And people just install their own stop sign, and later remember seeing it. I do feel like you're showing here the different ways in which memory can become contaminated. One is just, I'm drawing an inference on my own
随后，这些推断开始感觉像是记忆，而这正是你现在所记住的。古代哲学家如柏拉图和亚里士多德将记忆比作蜡板上的刻痕。亚里士多德提出心脏是身体的学习中心，因此有了“铭记于心”（learning by heart）这个短语。
and leading myself to a false conclusion. And in the next case, someone else is very subtly leading me to a wrong conclusion. And both of those things can be going on at different times or to steal your wonderful term. It could be a mishmash. But we do know that people do draw inferences about what might have happened, what could have happened, what probably happened.
在19世纪，德国学者赫尔曼·艾宾浩斯发现记忆随时间推移而退化，而持续重复是保持记忆的关键。西格蒙德·弗格森理论化地认为，有些记忆是如此难以忍受的痛苦，以至于它们被压抑到了潜意识中。所有这些都是基于一种模型，即人类记忆像录音设备一样工作。贝丝的研究表明，记忆同样关乎推断、想象和暗示性。志愿者们不仅没有仅仅检索记录下来的东西，反而在构建事件，并把这些虚构当作回忆蒙混过关。
And later on, those inferences kind of start to feel like memories, and that's what you now remember. Ancient philosophers like Plato and Aristotle compared memory to carvings on a wax tablet. Aristotle proposed that the heart was the learning center of the body, thus the phrase learning by heart.
正如我经常表达的那样，记忆的工作方式不像录音设备。你知道，只是记录事件并在后来回放。这个过程要复杂得多，这就是为什么我们谈论记忆的建设性本质。当我们回忆事情时，我们经常提取经验的零星片段，有时是发生在不同时间和地点的事件，将它们组合在一起，构建出在我们看来像是记忆的东西。这就是为什么我们谈论记忆的建设性或重构性本质。贝丝认为，“我们是我们记忆的总和”这句经典名言需要一个补充。
In the 19th century, German scholar Hermann Ebbinghaus found that memories deteriorate over time and that constant repetition was key to preserving memory. Sigmund Freud theorized that some memories were so unbearably painful that they were repressed into the subconscious mind. All these were based on a model that human memory worked like a recording device. Beth's study showed that memory was as much about inference, imagination, and suggestibility. Rather than merely retrieving something that was recorded, volunteers were constructing events and passing off these inventions as recollections.
我们的记忆不仅是我们所见所闻的总和，也是我们的想法、信念以及我们想要相信的东西的总和。她写道，我们似乎在重塑我们的记忆，在这个过程中，我们成为了自己想象中的那个人。贝丝的研究对刑事司法系统的顶梁柱——目击者证言的可靠性提出了质疑。通常，这种证据被视为稳操胜券。但在试图模仿此类情况下发生的事情的一系列实验中，
The way I've often put it, memory doesn't work like a recording device. You know, just record the event and play it back later. The process is much more complex and that's why we talk about the constructive nature of memory. That when we're remembering things, we're frequently taking bits and pieces of experience, sometimes things that happen at different times and places, bringing it together to construct what feels to us like a memory. And that's why we talk about the constructive or reconstructive nature of memory. Beth argues that the classic phrase, we are the sum of our memories, needs an addendum.
贝丝提出，我们对目击者证言的集体信任可能是错置的。她为志愿者策划了一起犯罪。这起犯罪显然是由一个人犯下的。现在你等上几天，然后要求你的证件查看六张照片，并试图挑出实施不良行为的人。坏人可能在那组照片中，也可能不在那组照片中。
Our memories are not just the sum of what we've seen and heard, but also what we think, what we believe, and what we want to believe. She writes, we seem to reinvent our memories, and in doing so, we become the person of our own imagination. Bet studies raised questions about the reliability of eyewitness testimony, a mainstay of the criminal justice system. Typically, this kind of evidence is treated as a slam dunk. But in one series of experiments that try to mimic what happens in such situations,
但许多人会挑出一个人，然后在最后的测试中，会有强烈的倾向再次选择同一个人，即使他们是无辜的，即使他们不是实施不良行为的人。但他现在看起来很面熟，因为他的照片被看到了，而不是因为他在事件本身中被看到。而这正是无辜的人被错认并被判犯下他们未曾做过的罪行时所发生的事情。
Bette suggested that our collective confidence in eyewitness testimony might be misplaced. She staged a crime for volunteers. The crime was clearly committed by one person. Now you wait a few days, and you ask your witnesses to look at six photos and try to pick the person who committed the bad act. The bad guy might be in that set of photos or he might not be in the set of photos.
所以在这种情况下，如果你愿意的话，这是对记忆的又一次微妙操控，因为我对自己见过某人的回忆使那张脸对我来说更熟悉了。所以下次你向我展示那张脸时，我很难区分我亲自挑出的脸和我在犯罪现场实际见过的脸，例如。我把这两件事混淆了，把它们合二为一了。完全正确。这种错误也会以其他方式发生。
But many people will pick someone and then in a final test, there'll be a strong tendency to pick that same person again, even if they're innocent, even if they were not the person who committed the bad act. But he now looks pretty familiar because his photograph was seen, not because he was seen in the event itself. And that is exactly what happens when innocent people get misidentified and get convicted of crimes they didn't do.
在一位律师写的关于目击者证言的早期书籍中有一个著名的例子，讲的是火车站的一名职员遭到抢劫，他去辨认队伍试图认出强盗并进行了辨认。但他挑选了一个在以前几次购买过他车票的人。所以你可以看到这里发生了什么。职员去了辨认队伍，他在队伍中看到了一个且仅有一个熟悉的面孔。他断定那就是强盗，
So in this case here, it's another for subtle memory manipulation, if you will, because my own recollection of having seen someone makes that face more familiar to me. So the next time you show me that face, I can't quite distinguish between a face that I myself picked out and a face that I might have actually seen at a crime scene, for example. I get mixed up between those two things and I conflate the two. Exactly. That kind of error can happen in other ways as well.
但这种熟悉感实际上是由于另一个原因，另一个理由。这就叫做无意识转移。对在一种情况下看到的人的错误回忆，让你以为他们在另一种情况下被看到。正是在这个时候，贝丝有机会参与了一起实际的法律案件。她当时在西雅图的华盛顿大学工作。那是一起谋杀案，一名女性是被告，她的辩护理由是自卫。控方称这是谋杀。案中的被告被指控杀害了一个男友，
There's a famous example in one of the early books on eyewitness testimony written by a lawyer of a clerk in a train station who was robbed and goes to a lineup to try to identify the robber and makes an identification. But he picks somebody who had purchased tickets from him on a few prior occasions. So you can see what's happening here. The clerk goes to the lineup, he sees one and only one person familiar in that lineup. He decides that that's the robber,
她指控该男友有虐待行为。这名女子承认她开枪打死了这名男子，但那是出于自卫。争议的焦点在于，这名女子拿起枪到开枪之间过去了多少时间。一些目击者称，仅仅过去了区区几秒钟，这表明这确实是正卫。另一些人则称，已经过去了数分钟，这表明谋杀是经过深思熟虑、蓄意预谋的。贝丝在法庭上就目击者证言的不可靠性作证。我要说的是，这名女子被判无罪。她被认定是在自卫的情况下实施这一行为的。
but that familiarity is really due to another cause, another reason. Then that's called an unconscious transference. The mistaken recollection of somebody who was seen in one situation and you think they were seen in a different situation. It was around this time that Beth got an opportunity to get involved with an actual legal case. She was working at the University of Washington in Seattle. It was a murder case where a woman was the defendant and her defense was self-defense. Prosecution said it was murder. The defendant in the case was accused of killing a boyfriend
所以这无疑是她和她律师的胜利。我为《今日心理学》杂志写了一篇文章。我写了关于这个案子，我写了那个女人。这篇文章发表后，我开始接到律师们的电话，你能帮我处理我的案子吗？1990年的有一天，贝丝接到了一位律师关于一个复杂案件的电话。乔治·富兰克林在加利福尼亚被指控谋杀。
whom she charged with being abusive. The woman admitted she shot the man, but in self-defense. At issue was how much time had gone by between the woman picking up the gun and firing it. Some eyewitnesses said mere seconds had passed, which suggested this was indeed self-defense. Others said minutes had elapsed, which suggested the killing was thought out, premeditated. Beth testified in court on the fallibility of eyewitness testimony. I will say that the woman was acquitted. She was found to have committed this act in self-defense.
他被指控在20年前谋杀了一个名叫苏西的小女孩。针对富兰克林的唯一证据是他女儿的证词，而女儿正是苏西最好的朋友。女儿艾琳声称，她目睹了父亲杀害自己最好的朋友，她将这段记忆压抑了20年，而现在记忆恢复了。现在我接到了乔治·富兰克林律师的电话，他叫道格·霍恩格勒，道格对我说，你知道的，我正在谋杀案中代表一个人，我对这个案子非常困惑，我想知道我能不能跟你谈谈这件事。那么你对这种压抑的概念有什么了解？
So it was certainly a victory for her and her lawyer. And I wrote an article for Psychology Today magazine. I wrote about the case, I wrote about the woman. And this article came out and I started getting calls from lawyers, could you help me with my case? One day in 1990, Beth got a call from an attorney about a complicated case. George Franklin was accused in California of murder.
我说，嗯，这是一种二手弗洛伊德式的观点，即不知何故，你可以把发生在你身上的所有这些可怕的事情，放逐到潜意识中，把它们与精神生活的其余部分隔离开来。但是，如果你采取了正确的程序，你以后仍然可以以某种纯洁的形式可靠地恢复它们。但当我开始寻找这种大规模压抑观念的证据时，我相当震惊，因为没有任何可信的科学支持这一点。无论如何，富兰克林还是受审了。他最终被定罪，实际上成为了第一个仅仅根据大规模压抑的主张而被定罪的美国公民。
He was accused of murdering a little girl named Susie 20 years earlier. And the only evidence against Franklin was the testimony of his daughter who was Susie's best friend, the daughter Eileen, claimed that she had witnessed her father kill her best friend, that she repressed her memory for 20 years and now the memory was back. Now I get a call from George Franklin's attorney, his name is Doug Horngrad, and Doug says to me, you know, I'm representing a man in a murder case and I am very confused about this case and I wonder if I could talk to you about it So what do you know about this idea of repression?
我当时有点震惊，就像律师们震惊于这就是定罪所需的全部内容一样。然后我们开始看到很多其他关于压抑的主张的案件。现在，你当时不可能确信这段记忆确实是假的，对吧？开始看到很多其他关于压抑的主张的案件。现在，你当时不可能确信这段记忆确实是假的，对吧？我的意思是，这是一个个案。在这起个案中，没有办法判断记忆是假的还是真的。
And I said well, it's a kind of a hand-me-down Freudian idea that somehow you can take all these horrific things that happen to you, banish them into the unconscious, wall them off from the rest of mental life. But still, you can kind of reliably recover them later in some pristine form if you have the right procedures applied to you. But when I started looking for the evidence for this notion of massive repression, I was pretty shocked because there wasn't any credible scientific support for this. So Franklin is tried anyhow. He ends up being convicted and becomes virtually the first American citizen
我无从得知，而且作为法庭上的专家，我也绝对不会妄下断言，因为我无从得知。但有些事情让我产生了怀疑。不过是的，你说得对。我的意思是，他还是有可能做过这件事的。但陪审团之所以定罪的部分原因，是因为她在回忆中拥有所有这些细节。如果她没有真正目睹她所声称的场景，这些细节会从哪里来呢？事实证明，所有的细节，几乎所有的细节都在公共领域，在报纸文章中，你知道的，在许多电视报道中，在
to be convicted based on nothing other than a claim of massive repression. And I was kind of amazed, as lawyers were amazed that this is all it took to convict. And then we started seeing lots of other cases of claims of repression. Now, you at this point could not have been sure that the memory in fact was false, right? started seeing lots of other cases of claims of repression. Now, you at this point could not have been sure that the memory, in fact, was false, right? I mean, this was an individual case. There's no way of telling in this individual case that memory is false or the memory is true.
在故事的电视报道中，细节就是从那里来的。我是富兰克林案的专家证人，但我能告诉陪审团的全部内容只是，我可以把让行标志变成停车标志，或者让某人相信那里有并不存在的碎玻璃。我从未真正让任何人相信他们有过可怕的经历，相信他们目睹了发生在自己身上的事情。这让我走上了一条想要弄清楚的道路，
I had no way of knowing, and I certainly wouldn't have said one way or another as an expert in court, since I had no way of knowing. But there were things that made me suspicious. But yeah, you're right. I mean, it's still possible, I suppose, that he could have done this. But part of the reason that the jury convicted is because she had all this detail in her recollection. Where would this detail have come from if she hadn't actually witnessed what she claimed? It turns out all that detail, virtually all that detail was in the public domain, in the newspaper articles of which, you know, there were many in the television coverage, in the
我想做一个研究，我们可以播下暗示的种子，看着它长得像艾琳·富兰克林声称自己拥有的那段记忆一样巨大。于是贝丝设计了一个后来变得著名的实验。它被称为“迷失在商场”研究。她招募了志愿者，但在向他们展示任何东西之前，她获得了他们的许可，可以与他们的家庭成员取得联系。
stories. the television coverage in the stories, there is where the detail could have come from. I was an expert witness for Franklin, but all I could tell the jury about was I could turn a yield sign into a stop sign or make somebody believe there was broken glass that wasn't there. I never really made anybody believe that they had a horrible experience, that they witnessed happen to them. It set me on a path of wanting to figure out,
我们向他们索取母亲、父亲或年长兄弟姐妹的名字，以便我们可以就他们的生活和记忆对他们进行采访。比方说，他们给了我们母亲的名字。我们会联系母亲，从母亲那里，我们获得三个经历的例子，即当被试大约五六岁时确实发生在被试身上事情。并且从母亲那里，我们还将构建
I wanna do a study where we could plant seeds of suggestion and watch it grow into something that is big as this memory that Eileen Franklin was claiming she had. So Beth devised an experiment that was to become famous. It was called the Lost in the Mall Study. She recruited volunteers, but before presenting anything to them, she got permission from them to get in touch with a family member.
一个虚构的场景，内容是五六岁时在购物中心迷路，有特定的家庭成员在场，最后被试据称被一位老年人救出并与家人团聚。你知道，那完全是一个虚构的人。完全是一个虚构的人。贝丝会向志愿者描述这三个真实的场景以及关于在商场迷路的虚假场景。一周后，她要求志愿者详细描述这些场景。他们对这些事件有什么记忆？
We asked them for the name of their mother or their father or an older sibling that we could interview about their life and their memories. So let's say they gave us their mother. We would contact the mother and from the mother, we would get three examples of experiences, things that really did happen to the subject when the subject was about five or six years old. And from the mother, we would also construct
在那之后的第二周，她要求他们再次复述这些场景。所以他们已经向我们提供了三次他们的回忆，到第三次时，我们发现大约四分之一的这些普通男女掉入了暗示的陷阱，并声称拥有一段记忆，一段关于以这种特定方式迷路的局部或全部记忆。嗯。他们中的一些人甚至回忆起你没有提供的细节，比如他们是怎么在商场迷路的，以及那是什么感觉？哦，当然。是的。有时他们会记住救他们的人长什么样。
a made-up scenario about being lost in a shopping mall at age five or six with particular family members present and ultimately the subject was supposedly rescued by an elderly person and reunited with the family. You know that was just a completely made up person. just a completely made up person. Beth would describe these three true scenarios and the false one about getting lost in a mall to volunteers. A week later, she asked the volunteers to describe the scenarios in detail. What did they remember about the events?
有时他们会记得一些事情，我想我听到大喇叭里喊我的名字了。这些细节根本不是我们最初为了将记忆植入大脑而与母亲一起构建的小场景的一部分。这给我留下深刻印象的是，你可以通过暗示，在人们的脑海中植入一整起事件。通过暗示在人们的脑海中植入一整起事件。当我们回来时，贝丝将测试她能让人相信的事物的极限。此外，当她在法庭上就她的发现作证时，她发现人们简直讨厌你告诉他们：虽然他们可能觉得自己确信，
The following week after that, she asked them to recount the scenarios again. So they've given us their recollections three times and by the third time we had found about a quarter of these ordinary men and women fell for the suggestion and claimed a memory, a partial or complete memory for having been lost in this particular way. Hmm. And some of them even recalled details that you had not provided about how they got lost in the mall and what it felt like? Oh, absolutely. Yes. Sometimes they remember what the person looked like, who rescued them.
他们对某件事的记忆分毫不差，但实际上，他们很可能记错了。你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。到20世纪90年代，心理学家贝丝·洛夫特斯经常被邀请出庭作证。许多案件涉及声称找回了遥远过去的创伤记忆的人。贝丝的观点是，虽然这些记忆可能感觉真实，但很有可能它们
Sometimes they'll remember things I think I heard my name over the loudspeaker. Details that weren't at all part of the initial little scenario that we had constructed with the mother in order to plant the memory in the first place. What impressed me about this is that you can, with suggestion, plant an entire event in the minds of people. with suggestion plant an entire event in the minds of people. When we come back, Beth tests the limits of what she can get people to believe. Also, as she begins testifying in court about her findings, she discovers that people simply hate it when you tell them that while they might feel certain,
是假的。为了展示这种情况是如何发生的，她证明了自己可以故意在志愿者心中植入虚假记忆。在她最初的一系列实验中，她让人们相信当他们还是小孩子时，曾在商场里迷路。但当贝丝公开展示这些数据时，其他专家批评了这项研究。批评者称，在商场迷路并不是法庭上人们所报告的那种极端创伤的例子。
they remember something exactly as it happened, chances are, they don't. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. By the 1990s, the psychologist Beth Laftis was regularly invited to testify in court. Many cases involved people who claimed to have recovered traumatic memories from the distant past. Beth's contention was that while these memories might feel real, there was a good chance they
我听到的最早的批评是，你知道，迷路太常见了。至少向我们证明，你能为那些比在购物中心迷路更令人不安、更离奇、更不同寻常的事情植入虚假记忆。说得好，但我们和其他许多人迎难而上，采用了这种设计来植入虚假记忆，这些事件如果真的发生过，将会更加离奇、不寻常，
were false. To show how this could happen, she proved she could deliberately implant false memories in volunteers. In her original set of experiments, she convinced people that when they were small children, they had gotten lost in a mall. But when Beth presented the data publicly, other experts criticized the study. The critics said that getting lost in a mall wasn't an example of the kind of extreme trauma that people were reporting in courtrooms.
或令人不安。一个小组植入了一个虚假记忆，即你在家庭婚礼上出了事故。另一个小组植入了一个虚假记忆，即你险些溺水，不得不由救生员施救。另一个小组植入了一个虚假记忆，即你险些溺水，不得不由救生员施救。另一个小组植入了一个虚假记忆，即童年时遭遇了诸如遭到恶性动物袭击这样可怕的事情。后来，另一个小组植入了一个虚假记忆，即你在十几岁时犯下了罪行，严重到警察都来调查了。所以我们现在拥有一整套研究，表明你可以将相当不寻常，
The earliest criticisms that I heard were, you know, getting lost is so common. At least show us that you can plant a false memory for something that would be more upsetting, more bizarre, more unusual than getting lost in a shopping mall. Good point, but we and others, many others, jumped to that challenge and used this design to plant false memories of things that would have been even more bizarre, unusual,
如果真的发生会相当令人不安、但完全是虚构的经历植入普通健康人的脑海中。你曾经做过一项研究，让人们记错了一个据称发生在迪士尼乐园的不寻常事件。贝丝，能讲讲那项研究吗？好的，对其中一些研究的另一个批评，我们称之为丰富的虚假记忆，而不是改变记忆中的细节。这里植入的是我们所说的丰富的虚假记忆。有时人们会顺着说，你知道，你和母亲谈过，母亲说这没有发生，
or upsetting if the event had actually happened. One group planted a false memory that you had an accident at a family wedding. Another group planted a false memory that you nearly drowned and had to be rescued by a lifeguard. Another group planted a false memory that you nearly drowned and had to be rescued by a lifeguard. Another group planted a false memory that something as awful as being attacked by a vicious animal happened to you as a child. Later, another group planted a false memory that as a teenager you committed a crime and it was serious enough that the police came to investigate. So we now have a whole collection of studies that show that you can plan pretty unusual
但也许发生了类似的事情而母亲并不知道。所以被试回忆的是确实发生过的事情。所以你可以有很多种回应方式，但其中一种是，好吧，让我们试着植入一件不可能发生、绝对不会发生的事情。这就是这个想法的起源。为什么不尝试植入一段记忆：当你童年去迪士尼旅行时，你遇到了
and pretty upsetting if they'd actually happened but completely made up experiences into the minds of ordinary healthy people. You once ran a study where you had people misremember an unusual event that supposedly took place at Disneyland. Tell me about that study, Beth. Well, okay, another criticism of some of these, we call them rich false memories, as opposed to changing a detail in a memory. Here it's planting what we call a rich false memory. Sometimes people will come along and they'll say, you know, you talked to the mother and the mother said it didn't happen,
兔八哥这个角色。我们选择这个是因为兔八哥是华纳兄弟的角色，不会出现在迪士尼度假区。所以这是一种近乎不可能的记忆。然而，当我们在研究中向人们暗示他们遇到了兔八哥时，许多人后来表示他们记得遇到了兔八哥。而且同样地，他们会记得与他握手、摸他的尾巴，或者听到他说：“怎么啦，医生？”
but maybe something like this happened and the mother isn't aware of it. And so what the subject is doing is recalling something that really did happen. So there are many ways you can respond, but one of them is, well well let's try to plant something that would be impossible that couldn't have happened. And that was the genesis of the idea. Why don't we try to plant a memory that when you were on a childhood trip to Disney you met
但也许类似的事情发生了，而母亲并不知道。因此，受试者所做的是在回忆一件确实发生过的事情。所以你可以有多种回应方式，其中之一就是，好吧，让我们试着植入一件不可能发生的事情。这就是这个想法的起源。为什么我们不试着植入这样一段记忆：当你在童年去迪士尼旅行时，你遇到了
the Bugs Bunny character. We picked that because Bugs is a Warner Brothers character, would not be at a Disney resort. So this is kind of an impossible memory. And yet, when we made a suggestion to people in a study that they had met Bugs Bunny, a number of people later on said they remembered meaning bugs. And again, they'll remember shaking his hand or touching his tail or hearing him say, what's up doc?
兔八哥这个角色。我们选择这个是因为兔八哥是华纳兄弟的角色，不会出现在迪士尼乐园里。所以这是一种不可能存在的记忆。然而，当我们在研究中向人们暗示他们遇到了兔八哥时，许多人后来表示他们确实记得遇到了兔八哥。同样，他们会记得跟它握手、摸它的尾巴，或者听到它说“怎么啦，老兄？”
One person even remembered he was eating a carrot when they met. So it is an example that just shows you can, well, you can't come back and say maybe it really happened. In a series of bizarre and escalating studies, Beth and others implanted implausible memories into study subjects. They remembered seeing a wounded animal after a bombing, or nearly choking to death death when in fact they had not. One in five believed they had as a child walked in on their parents having sex or witnessed someone else possessed by a demon. In a follow-up to the Disneyland
甚至有人记得他们见面时他正在吃胡萝卜。所以，这是一个例子，它向你表明，嗯，你不能回头说也许它真的发生了。在一系列离奇且不断升级的研究中，贝丝和其他人将貌似合理的记忆植入到研究对象脑中。他们记得在轰炸后看到一只受伤的动物，或者差点窒息而死，而事实上他们并没有。五分之一的人相信他们小时候曾撞见父母过性生活，或者目睹别人被恶魔附身。在迪士尼乐园的后续活动中
study 30% of volunteers falsely recalled a drugged-up Pluto mascot licking their ears. Scott licking their ears. Betts research proved timely. Five years after George Franklin was sentenced to life in prison, a judge overturned his conviction. By the case sparked a wave of similar ones. Hundreds of adults suddenly remembered long ago childhood sexual abuse. The idea was the events were so traumatic, the mental wounds so deep that
研究表明，30%的志愿者错误地回忆起一个吸毒过量的普鲁托吉祥物舔了他们的耳朵。斯科特舔了他们的耳朵。贝茨的研究被证明很及时。在乔治·富兰克林被判终身监禁五年后，一名法官推翻了他的定罪。此案引发了一系列类似案件。数百名成年人突然回想起很久以前童年遭受的性虐待。这个想法是，这些事件太具有创伤性，心理创伤太深，以至于
their minds simply blocked out the memories to protect them from pain. What there were a lot of is people who claimed they repressed their memory for massive sexual abuse and childhood trauma, all allegedly repressed and now recovered and they sued their parents or their other relatives or their former neighbors. So throughout the 90s there were many many many cases where there were these kinds of accusations and I was involved in some of those court cases. And just to be clear when you were testifying in some of these cases and you were writing, you were not necessarily saying that the people who recalled being sexually assaulted by their
他们的头脑只是简单地屏蔽了这些记忆，以保护他们免受痛苦。有很多这样的人，他们声称自己压抑了对大规模性虐待和童年创伤的记忆，所有这些据称都被压抑了，现在又恢复了，他们起诉了他们的父母、其他亲戚或前邻居。所以在整个90年代，有非常非常非常多的案件都存在这种指控，我参与了其中一些案件。需要明确的是，当你在其中一些案件中作证并写作时，你并不一定是在说那些回忆起自己遭到性侵犯的人。
uncles or their fathers, for example, were necessarily suffering from false memories. You were arguing that it was possible that these memories in fact might not be reliable, not that the memories in fact were false. Absolutely. And I mean, for ages I have been, because the opposing side would often present an expert witness who would bless the memory and in so many words say that they believe the memory was real. And I felt people had no business doing that without independent corroboration. I was certainly not gonna make the, you know, the opposite mistake, but that didn't matter.
例如，他们的叔叔或父亲不一定患有虚假记忆。你争论的是，这些记忆实际上可能并不可靠，而不是记忆实际上是假的。当然。我的意思是，多年来我一直这样，因为对方经常会请来一位专家证人，对记忆进行赞美，并用很多话来说他们相信记忆是真的。我觉得人们在没有独立证实的情况下这样做是毫无道理的。我当然不会犯相反的错误，但这并不重要。
And people just assumed, even though I was doing, was presenting an alternative possibility for what could have happened if these memories weren't real, where could they have come from? And I do emphasize if they weren't real. But that didn't matter because that little nuance seemed to get lost in people's anger over the mere thought that you would be on a call by the defense in one of these types of cases.
人们只是认为，尽管我所做的是为这些记忆如果不是真的可能会发生的事情提出一种替代的可能性，但它们可能来自哪里？我确实强调，如果它们不是真的。但这并不重要，因为这种细微差别似乎在人们对你会被其中一类案件的辩方召集的这种想法的愤怒中迷失了。
Did you feel like you were doing something wrong here, Beth? Because the people who were bringing these charges, obviously, felt like they had been abused in the most terrible way and had been hurt and scarred in the most terrible way. And here's a university professor basically standing up and testifying on behalf of the defense. Did you ever feel like you were on the morally wrong side of the equation?
贝丝，你觉得自己在这里做了什么错事吗？因为那些提出这些指控的人，很显然，觉得自己受到了最可怕的方式的虐待，受到了最可怕的伤害和创伤。这里有一位大学教授基本站出来为辩方作证。你有没有觉得自己站在了道德错误的一边？
No, I can't say that I ever felt I was morally wrong because remember at these times, there are other human beings in this story. There's the accused in the story and the family members of that accused and the suffering and the sadness and the ruined families. And so I never felt it was morally wrong. But sometimes what I did feel is that I would have a reaction to stories I would hear that was different from what a lot of other people had. So for example, when I read about a new accusation in my morning paper while I'm having my coffee
不，我不能说我曾经觉得自己道德上有错，因为记住，在这个时候，这个故事里还有其他人。这个故事里有被告，有被告的家属，还有痛苦、悲伤和破碎的家庭。所以我从来不觉得这在道德上有错。但有时我确实觉得，我对听到的故事的反应与许多其他人不同。例如，当我一边喝着咖啡，一边在早报上读到一篇新的指控时
and some new person is accusing some other person, I mean, one of my first thoughts is I wonder if this is a false accusation, but many other people around me, the guillotine isn't good enough for the accused right at that moment. But I don't think that I'm the morally wrong one. Beth saw herself as obligated to follow the science, even if it wasn't the popular thing to do. As an expert who says human memory is fallible and malleable, Beth has been asked to testify in many cases where defendants have been accused of wrongdoing.
某个新人在指控另一个人，我的第一反应之一是我想知道这是一个虚假指控，但我周围的许多其他人，对于被告来说，断头台在那一刻还不够好。但我并不认为我是道德上有错的一个。贝丝认为自己有义务遵循科学，即使这不是一件受欢迎的事情。作为一名称人类记忆容易出错且具有可塑性的专家，贝丝曾被邀请在许多被告被指控犯罪的案件中作证。
These include controversial cases such as O.J. Simpson, Ted Bundy, the officers who beat Rodney King, and more recently in the Me Too era, Bill Cosby and Harvey Weinstein. recently in the Me Too era, Bill Cosby and Harvey Weinstein. I found it especially remarkable that Beth was willing to serve as an expert witness for men accused of sexual harassment and assault. Because as I was researching her life, I came by an account of something that happened to her
这些案件包括备受争议的案件，如辛普森、特德·邦迪、殴打罗德尼·金的警官，以及最近在“我也是”运动（Me Too）时期的比尔·科斯和哈维·韦恩斯坦。最近在“我也有”时代，比尔·科斯和哈维·韦恩斯坦。我发现特别引人注目的是，贝丝愿意为被指控性骚扰和袭击的男性担任专家证人。因为当我研究她的人生时，我偶然发现了一件发生在她身上的事情
during her childhood. It was the third traumatic event I mentioned earlier. I was involved in a case where a young camp counselor got accused of abusing kids in the camp. And I was testifying about the science of memory. And I was being cross-examined by the prosecutor. And a standard cross-examination that I get get is you're not a clinician, you don't treat people who have been sexually abused. So what do you know about that? I don't know why I did this,
在她童年时期。这就是我前面提到的第三个创伤事件。我参与了一个案件，一个年轻的营地辅导员被指控虐待营地里的孩子。我正在作证关于记忆的科学。我正在接受检察官的盘问。我经常遇到的标准盘问是，你不是临床医生，你不治疗遭受性虐待的人。那你对此了解什么？我不知道我为什么要这么做，
but I was getting badgered and I finally said, well, as a matter of fact, I do know something about that because I was sexually abused when I was six. And the words just kind of came out of my mouth. It's not like it was the first time I had, when I was an adult, I told my then husband, Jeff, about the experience. He was the first person I ever told. And I was in my 20s when I told him,
但我受到了纠缠，我终于说，好吧，事实上，我对那确实有所了解，因为我在六岁时遭到性虐待。这些话就这样脱口而出。这并不是我第一次，当我成年后，我把这段经历告诉了我当时的的丈夫杰夫。他是我告诉的第一个人。当我告诉他时，我二十多岁，
and this was quite a bit later. So it's not like it was the first time, but certainly the first time I blurted it out publicly and my first reaction was, oh my God, I don't want them to think it was my father. So I added that it was a babysitter. What actually happened, Beth? Well, he was a babysitter, so he would have been babysitting for me. I don't know, he used to caress my arm one time. We went into the bedroom and he laid me on top of him, and I squirmed my way off, and
这已经是很久以后了。所以这并不是第一次，但绝对是第一次我公开脱口而出，我的第一反应是，哦，天哪，我不想让他们以为那是我父亲。所以我补充说那是保姆。实际上发生了什么，贝丝？嗯，他是个保姆，所以他本该照顾我。我不知道，他曾经抚摸过我的手臂一次。我们走进卧室，他把我放在他身上，我扭动着身体爬了下来，
that's what I remember. Hmm. I mean, what I've read in terms of your recollections of the event, it was if he didn't just lay you on top of him, he actually removed your clothes. Is that correct? I don't remember that. I think one of the times I wrote about this
这就是我所记得的。嗯。我的意思是，根据你对这件事的回忆，不仅仅是你把他放在他身上，他实际上脱掉了你的衣服。是这样吗？我不记得了。我想我写过这件事的其中一次
would have been more than 25 years ago and I would trust that memory a little more than my memory now. But I don't remember him taking the clothes off. I mean, isn't it striking that a detail like that would be something that would feel ambiguous? Because I think in the past, when you've written about it, you have recalled that, and now you don't recall that. Isn't it remarkable that something as significant as that would be malleable and open to change? Well, I don't know, but as you're pointing this out, and I'm assuming you're just accurately recounting to me what I wrote 25 years ago, I'm starting to visualize it, Shankar. I'm starting to visualize it and I'm
可能已经是25年多以前的事了，我对那时的记忆会比现在的记忆更信任一些。但我不记得他脱了衣服。我的意思是，像这样的细节会让人感到模棱两可，这难道不引人注目吗？因为我认为在过去，当你写到它时，你曾回忆过，而现在你不记得了。像这样重要的事情竟然具有可塑性并会发生变化，这难道不引人注目吗？嗯，我不知道，但当你指出这一点时，我假设你只是准确地向我复述了我25年前写的东西，香卡，我开始想象它了。我开始想象它，我
starting to think, yeah, maybe he did pull the pants down because he was on his back. I think he laid me on top of him and I would have been face down. I don't think I was there of way. I have to say there's an element of this research that seems frightening, Beth, because I think when we think about our own memories, our memories seem so real to us and feel like they anchor us to our past, to the people we love, the events in our lives. And in some ways what you're doing is taking something of a sledgehammer to our confidence in our own memories. Well, I understand that that upsets people. And I particularly understand that when I say something that other people hear as a doubt
开始想，是的，也许他确实脱下了裤子，因为他是仰面朝天的。我想他把我放在他身上，我肯定是脸朝下。我不认为我在那儿。我必须说，这项研究有一个令人恐惧的元素，贝丝，因为我认为当我们思考自己的记忆时，我们的记忆对我们来说似乎非常真实，感觉就像把我们锚定在我们的过去，我们爱的人，我们生活中的事件上。从某种意义上说，你正在做的事情是对我们对自己的记忆的信心的一种重锤。嗯，我理解这会让人心烦意乱。我尤其理解，当我说了别人听到怀疑的话时
about the authenticity of their memory that that can be upsetting. But I also think that this is a truth about memory and we need to recognize that truth. We need to then figure out ways to live with it or combat it or fix it or minimize the harms of it. Because a lot of harm has come from mistaken memory. I don't like it when people contradict my memories.
关于他们记忆的真实性，这可能会让人心烦意乱。但我也认为这是关于记忆的一个事实，我们需要认识到这个事实。我们需要弄清楚如何与它共存，或者对抗它，或者修复它，或者尽量减少它的危害。因为错误的记忆已经带来了很多伤害。当人们反驳我的记忆时，我很不喜欢。
That sometimes has happened and it makes me very uncomfortable and I see why other people are uncomfortable too. Especially a cherished memory. Hmm. I mean I'm wondering what your takeaway is for people because in some uncomfortable too, especially a cherished memory. I mean, I'm wondering what your takeaway is for people, because in some ways I think what you have done is you've clearly demonstrated that memory is a shaky edifice, if you will, and constructed by the mind as we move through our lives. But what should ordinary people do with this, Beth? Well, I sometimes get asked, why would we have been built this way? Whatever your theory is, why would God or Darwin or whoever have created humans with memories that are malleable? And there are certain benefits.
这有时会发生，这让我很不舒服，我也明白为什么其他人也会不舒服。尤其是珍贵的记忆。嗯。我的意思是，我想知道你给人们带来了什么收获，因为在某些方面也不舒服，尤其是珍贵的记忆。我的意思是，我想知道你给人们带来了什么收获，因为在某些方面，我认为你所做的是你清楚地证明了记忆是一个摇摇欲坠的大厦，如果你愿意的话，是由心灵在我们度过一生时构建的。但普通人应该如何对待这一点，贝丝？嗯，有时有人问我，我们为什么要这样被构建？无论你的理论是什么，为什么上帝或达尔文或任何人会创造出具有可塑性记忆的人类？这其中有一定的益处。
So for example, when errors creep into our memories, which they do spontaneously or from some other process, and we find out we can update our memories, correct the information, replace the errors with truth. That's a good thing. Other people have suggested that some memories maybe make us feel better about ourselves. People remember that they gave more to charity or they voted in elections, they didn't vote in or their kids walked and talked at earlier ages than they really did?
因此，例如，当错误潜入我们的记忆中时，它们是自发发生的还是通过其他过程发生的，我们发现我们可以更新记忆，纠正信息，用真相取代错误。这是一件好事。其他人提出，有些记忆可能会让我们对自己的感觉更好。人们记得他们向慈善机构捐了更多的钱，或者他们在他们没有投票的选举中投了票，或者他们的孩子比实际年龄更早地走路和说话？
These are prestige enhancing memories that maybe make us feel a little bit better about ourselves. Maybe that could be a good thing. But isn't your work also in some ways a call for intellectual and moral humility because it tells us that perhaps we shouldn't be as confident in believing we know what we know, we remember what we remember, we think what we think. I love that. I believe that this is telling us that potentially there is a lot of fiction sprinkled in there, in our minds along with the facts. And this is maybe a truth that we should
这些是增强声望的记忆，也许能让我们对自己感觉好一点。也许这可能是一件好事。但你的工作在某种程度上难道不是对智力和道德谦逊的呼吁吗？因为它告诉我们，也许我们不应该那么自信地相信我们知道我们所知道的，我们记得我们所记得的，我们认为我们所想的。我喜欢这个。我相信这告诉我们，在我们的头脑中，除了事实之外，可能还夹杂着大量的虚构。这也许是一个事实，我们应该
figure out how to respond to if it's gonna be a problem or accept and deal with and live with, just like we might have blurry bad vision and we fix it with glasses or contact lenses and you know for me as somebody who's been working in this field and seeing how easy it is for people to come to believe and remember things that didn't happen. When you see someone make a mistake in their memory, when somebody disagrees with you
弄清楚如何应对，如果它将成为一个问题，或者接受并处理并与之共存，就像我们可能有视力模糊的不良视力，然后我们用眼镜或隐形眼镜来修复它，你知道，对于我来说，作为一个在这个领域工作的人，看到人们是多么容易相信和记住没有发生的事情。当你看到有人在记忆中犯错时，当有人不同意你的观点
and you're pretty convinced your memory is right, at least you don't have to decide that your fellow human is a big fat liar. You can appreciate the fact that they just might have a false memory in their human. And I think that is a much kinder way to feel about our family members, our friends, our acquaintances, our others who, who say something that we don't agree with. Elizabeth Laftis is a psychologist at the University of California, Irvine. She is the
而你相当确信你的记忆是正确的，至少你不需要认定你的同胞是个彻头彻尾的骗子。你可以欣赏这样一个事实，即他们可能只是在他们的人类中存在错误的记忆。我认为对于我们的家庭成员、朋友、熟人、以及其他说出我们不同意的话的人，这是一种更善良的感觉。伊丽莎白·洛夫蒂斯是加州大学尔湾分校的心理学家。她是
author of The Myth of Repressed Memory and witness for the defense, the accused, the eyewitness and the expert who puts memory on trial. Oh, my pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Corell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you like the show, please check out our new app. It's called Hidden Brain Daily Challenge and you can find it in the Apple App Store. Hidden Brain Daily Challenge is where you'll find our first game designed to help you improve
《被压抑记忆的神话》和《为辩护人、被告、目击者以及将记忆置于审判之中的专家作证》的作者。哦，我的荣幸。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·黄、拉娜·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行主编。如果你喜欢这个节目，请查看我们的新应用程序。它叫做Hidden Brain日常挑战，你可以在苹果应用商店找到它。Hidden Brain日常挑战是你找到我们第一个旨在帮助你提高的游戏的地方
your facial recognition skills. We're hoping that this app will eventually feature other fun games and exercises that are designed to sharpen your mind and test your wits. Give it a try and leave us a review. We'd love to know what you think. Again, that's Hidden Brain Daily Challenge, available now in the Apple App Store. I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你的面部识别技能。我们希望这款应用程序最终能推出其他旨在磨练你的思维和测试你的智慧的有趣游戏和练习。试一试，给我们留下评论。我们很想知道你的想法。再次强调，这就是Hidden Brain日常挑战，现在可以在苹果应用商店下载。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，我们很快再见。您 这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。